n'est ce pas bonjour vous étiez là vous
tombez bien aujourd'hui c'est la saint
casimir oui c'est la fête de casimir et
moi j'ai acheté un joli cadeau à
regarder c'est bien non ça je suis sûr
que ça lui fera une bonne surprise aux
des affiches c'est la saint casimir
c'est ma fête eh ben ça alors comme
surpris je crois que c'est plutôt raté
dc qu'aujourd'hui c'est la saint casimir
je les regarde je vois que je ne la
prends à personne oui et surtout pas à
kazim et à bompas québécois que c'est
lui qui a été laissé à fixe enfin juline
n'importe qui toi moi moi les enfants
qui est capable d'écrire c'est la saint
casimir
mais seuls casimir été capable d'écrire
c'est ma fête
jack et dire que je lui avait réservé
une surprise
un joli cadeau howie lequel revoir
encore j'ai trouvé chez un brocanteur à
vieux livres de cuisine qui indique la
recette du gloubiboulga le gloubiboulga
traditionnel oui formidable alors
écoutez bien écouter les enfants
écoutez dans une grande assiette ou un
récipient mettre une banane dont on aura
au préalable enlever la peau la couper
en rondelles
râpez finement si carré de chocolat au
lait puis 50 grammes ou de cuillère de
confiture de fraise écrasée doucement le
tout en mélangeant bien et puis un petit
additifs pour les casimir us a ajouté 20
g de l'outarde est une saucisse de
toulouse cru mais tiède mais c'est très
intéressant ce jeu mais casimir ne leur
ai dit que seuls les casimir us mettait
de la moutarde et de la saucisse de
toulouse cru métier
et voilà et le livre de cuisine
mentionne que si on met seulement la
confiture de fraise
le chocolat est là-bas dame ça s'appelle
le gloubiboulga des enfants je dis moi
j'ai bien envie de me faire un gloubi
boulga comme les enfants et vous dis moi
françois qui s'était tu lui apportes loi
regarde une magnifique paire de ciseaux
a coupé le caoutchouc mais c'est très
originaire comme cadeau mais à quoi s'en
servir à tignes on july met mais pour
confectionner son dessert favori
il prendra la paire de ciseaux il
découpera en petit confetti ses morceaux
de chambres à air et il mélangera le
tout avec sa crème chanter vase est une
excellente idée je suis sûre que celle
ralliera certainement
bonjour mes très chers amis je me suis
dit c'est beau jeu avant d'aller vous
comme ça pour tout vous dire je suis
fâché je croyais être le seul et le
premier avant penser à l'instinct kazimi
te dire que casino a vraiment été le
tout premier à annoncer à sa fais mes
chers amis je trouve ça particulièrement
agaçant nous de ton du dernier mois
votre verre au monsieur monsieur du snob
mais pour être plus calme quelques
mouvements de gymnastique actifs
d'essayer mais c'est vous baissez vous
m'avez vous y voilà et c'est vous
devez-vous mais prend l'air mais prend
les sur les côtés des petits ciseaux top
top un peu de course à pied en direction
du bain en petites foulées et voilà
aulas est mal à la tête mais tour
sentais bien et notre rôle à la tête me
tourne mon verre oui mon bon mec vous
inquiétez pas monsieur du snop jolie mis
dans la poubelle il s'alliera plus le
jardin dans la poubelle mais c'est ma
dernière génial sculpture pour la fête
de casimir hayon excusez moi monsieur
19,6 regardez et il n'est pas du tout à
biner merci bien maintenant il ne nous
reste plus qu'à attendre quasiment oui
j'ai malheureusement avec toutes ces
pancartes nos surprises ne seront plus
des survols écouter métiers du synode
réuni je crois qu'ils font quand même
réservé à casimir une bonne petite
surprise qu'il verra
bonjour mes amis vous avez mes cadeaux
quel cadeau mon beau casimir quoi
devrions-nous temps fait mais il n'y a
aucune raison mais enfin c'est ma fête
la saint casimir
mais franchement casimir c'est ce que je
croyais avant d'avoir vu les ponts cas
ni comment mais c'est en car c'est moi
qui les ai posé pour vous rappeler que
c'était ma feinte alors casimir
regardez les ce n'est pas ce qui est
écrit 1
c'est par à saint-casimir s'offre à vous
avez voulu me faire une farce mais fait
pourquoi tu dis ça parce que vous avez
rajouté le maupas se répand car pourquoi
n'es tu si sûr mais enfin parce que moi
à casimir je n'aurais jamais fait une
faute de francs c'est pareil on ne dit
pas c'est pas la saint casimir mais ce
n'est pas la saint casimir
je sais que c'est incroyable à un mot
casimir à retenir
tu as bien méritée cas de besoin
[Musique]